IT’S A MESS DOWN THERE.
LET’S BRING IN SOMEBODY LIVE ON
THE COUCH IT’S GREAT TO HAVE
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
>> I DON’T KNOW IF THIS IS LIVE
BUT I’M HERE.
BRIAN:  OH, YOU ARE LIVE.
THE UNITED NATIONS IS HERE FIRST
OFF ON THE BORDER CRISIS YOU
SAID THERE’S ONE THING WE CAN DO
RIGHT NOW.
>> EVERYBODY IS COMING TO SEEK
ASYLUM.
IF YOU SAID YOU CAN’T APPLY FOR
ASYLUM IN THE UNITED STATES,
WE NO LONGER ACCEPT ASYLUM
CLAIMS INSIDE THE COUNTRY, THAT
ALL STOPPED COMING, TRUMP DID
THAT AND IT WENT TO A 45-
YEAR-OLD --
BRIAN:  FIRST COUNTRY YOU’RE IN.
>> IF YOU’RE FROM THE TRIANGLE
COUNTRIES YOU APPLY THERE, AND
IF YOU COME FROM SOME OTHER
PLACE WE SEND YOU BACK TO MEXICO
AND YOU SIT IN MEXICO AND MAKE
YOUR APPLICATION, YOU CAN’T COME
HERE UNTIL YOUR HEARING WHICH IS
THREE OR  FOUR YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD AND IT ALL STOPS
OVERNIGHT.
NOBODY WILL PAY A PUNCH BUNCH OF
MONEY TO SIT IN MEXICO FOR FIVE
YEARS.
STEVE: NO KIDDING.
WE WERE CHATTING IN THE GREEN
ROOM BRIEFLY AND YOU WERE KIND
OF RECOUNTING EVERYTHING THAT’S
GONE HAYWIRE.
WANT YOU TO LOOK AT A TWEET FROM
AN ASSOCIATED PRESS REPORTER
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, HE TWEETED
OUT YESTERDAY, THE PENTAGON
ADMITTED ITS DRONE STRIKE, COVID
BOOSTERS DID NOT GET FULL
APPROVAL, FRANCE
RECALLED THE AMBASSADOR,
PUNISHING HEADLINES ALL WITHIN
AN HOUR ON FRIDAY, UNDERSCORED
THE  PERILS FOR A PRESIDENT FROM
UNCONTROLLABLE EVENTS THAT CAN
DEFINE A TERM.
WERE THESE UNCONTROLLABLE EVENTS
OR  WAS THIS ALL JUST KIND OF
BAD STRATEGY FROM THE BIDEN
PEOPLE?
>> HE CHOSE POORLY AT EVERY
TURN.
IF HE HAD DONE NOTHING ON THE
BORDER WE’D BE OKAY.
HE CHANGED THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY AND DID AWAY WITH THE
ASYLUM AGREEMENTS FOR THE
TRAIN COUNTRIES GUESS
WHAT WE’RE OVERRUN, LIKE THE
BORDER PATROL TOLD THE
TRANSITION TEAM OF BIDEN IN
DECEMBER AND JANUARY, IF HE
LEFT THE TROOPS AT BAGRAM, NEVER
CLOSED BAGRAM AIR BASE WE
WOULDN’T HAVE THE TALIBAN IN
CHARGE.
IF HE KEEPS SPENDING MONEY LIKE
THIS WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
INFLATION THROUGH THE ROOF.
ALL THIS IS SELF-INFLICTED BUT
THERE’S A PERFECT STORM BREWING
GUYS.
THE CHAOS IN THE MID EAST IS
GOING TO COME TO US HERE AT HOME
THROUGH THE BORDER IF WE DON’T
CHANGE SOON.
STEVE: HOW?
>> JUST HOW EASY WOULD IT BE
FOR A TERRORIST GROUP TO HIRE
SOME CARTEL TO TAKE THEM INTO
THE UNITED STATES THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, GET IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS HUMANITY,
LIKE THE HAITIANS THEY AREN’T
SENDING HAITIANS BACK, THEY ARE
SENDING MEN BACK AND THE WOMEN
AND CHILDREN ARE STAYING SO
NOTHING CHANGES UNTIL YOU CHANGE
OUR ASYLUM LAW BUT I’M REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT THE NARRATIVE OUT
THERE THAT AMERICA WAS DEFEATED
IN AFGHANISTAN, EVERY JIHADIST
IS GOING TO AFGHANISTAN
AND THERE WILL SOON BE AN EFFORT
TO INFILTRATE THIS COUNTRY
THROUGH THE SOUTHERN BORDER OF
WE DON’T DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AINSLEY: JUST A MATTER OF TIME?
>> MATTER OF TIME AND TIME IS
RUNNING OUT.
THE CHATTER AND I DON’T WANT TO
SCARE PEOPLE, THE CHATTER IS
REAL.
STEVE: ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
STUFF YOU HEAR BECAUSE YOU’RE ON
SECRET COMMITTEES?
>> WELL IT’S NOT SO MUCH, WE
HEAR THINGS THE AVERAGE PERSON
DOESN’T BUT THE CHATTER OUT
THERE IS REALLY REAL.
AL QAEDA AND THE TALIBAN ARE ONE
IN THE SAME.
THERE WILL BE AN EFFORT TO
NORMALIZE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
TALIBAN, AND IT WILL BE A
DISASTER, ANY MONEY YOU PAY THEM
DOESN’T GO TO THE PEOPLE OF
AFGHANISTAN, IT GOES TO THEM,
AND THEY WILL GIVE SAVE HAVEN TO
AL QAEDA BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
THE SAME.
THEY HAVE A COMMON PURPOSE.
AINSLEY: WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO
THE FACT THAT WE STILL HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THERE?
WE HAVE NOT ONLY OUR ALLIES BUT
WE DO HAVE AMERICANS THERE.
THEY ARE SAYING MAYBE 100 I’VE
HEARD 100 OR  200.
>> WHO KNOWS.
AINSLEY: EXACTLY.
>> MY REACTION IS THIS IS SELF-
INFLICTED, IF YOU LEFT THE
MILITARY IN COUNTRY AND GOT
ALL OF THE CIVILIANS OUT FIRST
LIKE A NORMAL PERSON YOU
WOULDN’T HAVE THIS PROBLEM.
WHO IN THE WORLD TAKES ALL OF
THE MILITARY OUT AND THEN HOPE
YOU CAN GET THE CIVILIANS OUT
LATER?
THIS IS A CASE STUDY AND JUST
SCREWING UP HOW TO WITHDRAW FROM
A COUNTRY.
BRIAN:  THE BOB WOODWARD BOOK
SAYS THAT MILLEY AS WELL AS HIS
SECRETARY OF STATE AS WELL AS
THE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE ALL RECOMMENDED HE DID
NOT PULL OUT ALL OF THE TROOPS,
ESPECIALLY THAT WAY.
HE SAID I APPRECIATE IT, I
LISTEN BUT I’M DOING IT MY WAY.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> NO.
SO THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
EVERYBODY IN HIS CIRCLE SAID
LEAVE A RESIDUAL FORCE.
LEAVE THE 2,500, KEEP BAGRAM,
IT’S AN INSURANCE POLICY AGAINST
ANOTHER 9/11.
IT WAS JOE BIDEN AND JOE BIDEN
ALONE WHO DECIDED TO PULL ALL
THE TROOPS OUT.
TRUMP TOLD ME LAST COUPLE OF
NIGHTS AGO, HE WOULD HAVE GET
BAGRAM.
IF YOU’D KEPT BAGRAM AND THE
CIA POST ALONG THE BORDER
THE TALIBAN COULD NEVER TAKE
OVER AND AL QAEDA COULDN’T COME
STORMING BACK LIKE THEY ARE
TODAY SO THIS IS GENERAL BIDEN
KNOWING MORE THAN ALL OF THE
GENERALS COMBINED AND HE WAS
TOLD BY EVERYBODY LEAVE A
RESIDUAL FORCE IT WAS HIS
DECISION TO PULL THE PLUG JUST
LIKE IT WAS IN IRAQ WITH HIM AND
OBAMA.
STEVE: SO MORE BAD NEWS FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, I BELIEVE IT
WAS SUNDAY NIGHT WHEN THE
PARLIAMENT FOR YOUR GROUP,
THE SENATE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE DEMOCRATS GOD BLESS THEIR
HEARTS TRYING TO DO THIS BUT YOU
CAN NOT INSERT MIGRATION CONTROL
OR  IMMIGRATION INTO THE
RECONCILIATION THING.
JUST CAN’T DO IT.
THE WAY THE RULES ARE SETUP, SO
NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
PLAN B.
WHAT’S THAT GOING TO LOOK LIKE?
>> NOBODY IS MORE HAPPY ABOUT
THIS RULING THAN THE DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU ACTUALLY PUT DACA
LEGALIZATION IN A RECONCILIATION
PACKAGE WE ONLY NEED 50
DEMOCRATIC VOTES THEY WOULD OWN
LEGAL LEGALIZING PROBABLY A
MILLION PEOPLE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE A RUN ON THE
BORDER IF WORD GOT OUT
TOMORROW, HEY THEY JUST GIVE A
MILLION PEOPLE LEGAL STATUS,
HURRY ON DOWN.
IF YOU LEGALIZE ONE PERSON
BEFORE YOU SECURE THE BORDER AND
REFORM A BROKEN IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM THE RUN ON THE BORDER
WILL BE WORSE THAN IT IS TODAY.
BRIAN:  THE 3.5 IS IT DEAD?
>> IT DEPENDS ON --
BRIAN:  CRADLE TO GRAVE SOCIAL
PROGRAMS.
>> I THINK PART OF IT IS.
I THINK AT MOST THEY WILL DO A
TRILLION, TRILLION AND A HALF,
THE 3.5 BILLION PACKAGE AS
WRITTEN IS DEAD.
IT’S AN INFLATION BOMB, I TALKED
TO MANCHIN A COUPLE NIGHTS AGO.
HE TOLD ME AND I DON’T KNOW IF
THIS IS ACCURATE THAT WE SPENT
MORE MONEY SINCE THE ONSET OF
COVID TO DEAL WITH COVID THAN WE
DID TO WIN WORLD WAR II AND THE
MARSHALL PLAN.
IF THAT’S TRUE, THEN WE NEED TO
SLOW DOWN, BECAUSE WE’RE GOING
TO CREATE INFLATION FOR DECADES
TO COME HERE IF WE DON’T WATCH
IT.
STEVE: PEOPLE ARE FEELING THAT
WITH THE HIGH PRICES.
AINSLEY: WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT,
HOW ARE WE GETTING OUR PEOPLE
BACK FROM AFGHANISTAN?
ARE WE NEGOTIATING WITH THE
TALIBAN?
>> THIS IS THE ULTIMATE
QUESTION.
WE NEED TO HAVE A HEARING AUNT
WHAT RELATIONSHIP WE HAVE WITH
AFGHANISTAN.
HOW DO YOU GET ON THE PLANE?
28 AMERICANS GOT ON A PLANE FROM
AFGHANISTAN TO QATAR, THANK YOU
TO QATAR.
WHAT SYSTEM IS IN PLAY TO GET
YOU ON THAT PLANE?
WHY DO YOU GET ON AND SOMEBODY
ELSE DOESN’T?
ARE WE PAYING MONEY TO THE
TALIBAN?
I WANT TO KNOW THE SYSTEM THAT’S
IN PLACE TO GET OUR PEOPLE OUT,
AND WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT THE
THOUSANDS OF AFGHAN
INTERPRETERS, TRANSLATORS AND
FIGHTERS WHO FOUGHT ALONG OUR
SIDE?
SO MY FEAR IS THAT THE TALIBAN
ARE MILKING US DRY, THAT THEY
ARE LETTING OUT SMALL GROUPS
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME TO
HAVE LEVERAGE OVER US AND I’D
LIKE TO TURN IT ON THEM AND I’D
LIKE TO SAY, YOU’VE GOT 30 DAYS
TO GET ALL OF OUR PEOPLE OUT OR
ELSE.
BRIAN:  WOW, THAT’S FASCINATING
TO FIND OUT, BECAUSE WE KNOW
WE’RE ABOUT TO WRITE A CHECK FOR
$64 MILLION FOR HUMANITARIAN
AID.
WHO GREEN-LIGHTED THAT.
DON’T THEY HAVE TO CHECK WITH
YOU BEFORE THEY GIVE AID OUT TO
A TERRORIST REGIME?
>> SO ALL OF US, A BUNCH OF
REPUBLICANS HAVE BILLS THAT SAY
NOT FOR THE TALIBAN.
THE WORLD FOOD PROGRAM, PEOPLE
ARE STARVING IN AFGHANISTAN, THE
ECONOMY IS COLLAPSED I DON’T
MIND HELPING INDIVIDUAL AFGHANS
BUT I DON’T WANT TO GIVE A DIME
TO THE TALIBAN.
THE TALIBAN ARE, IN FACT, THE
BENEFACTOR OF AL QAEDA.
WE GOT TO ATTACK ONCE WHEN THEY
WERE IN CHARGE, WE’RE GOING TO
GET  ATTACKED TWICE THE SECOND
TIME IF WE DON’T WATCH IT AND
ISIS IS COMING AFTER THEM.
15% APPROVAL RATING BY THE
TALIBAN.
HOW DO THEY RUN THIS COUNTRY?
SO IF WE PROP THEM UP, IT’LL BE
THE BIGGEST MISTAKE SINCE THE
WITHDRAWAL.
THE LAST THING YOU WANT TO DO IS
PROVIDE AID AND COMFORT AMERICAN
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO KEEP A
TERRORIST GROUP IN CHARGE OF
AFGHANISTAN TO PAID THE WAY FOR
THE FIRST 9/11 AND THAT’S
WHAT BIDEN IS ABOUT TO DO.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO CREATE A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE UNITED
STATES AND THE WESTERN WORLD,
WHERE WE PROP UP THE TALIBAN AND
WE WILL LIVE TO REGRET THAT.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM, GREAT TO HAVE
SOMEBODY ON THE COUCH.
THERE’S A LOT GOING ON.
>> THERE’S SOMETHING BETTER I
JUST DON’T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
STEVE: AS YOU STARTED YOU SAID
IT’S A BIG MESS AND GIVES US
PLENTY TO TALK ABOUT.
BRIAN:  THIS MONTH WE’LL FIND